a couple of big destiny related things
happened over the weekend including the
news that those of you currently play
won't be getting any daily or weekly
events in the coming week Bungie wrote
on its website when destiny 2.0 update
releases there will be no weekly or
daily event might fall daily heroic
story heroic strike available for the
week of sep tember 82 September 14 2015
the 2.0 has arrived on sep tember 8 and
is a major update changing all sorts of
bits and pieces the full list of which
you can check out in a story on gamespot
Destiny's third expansion the taken king
is due out a week after the update lands
on sep 10 to 15 in other Bungie related
things the publisher has just lost a
legal battle with former halo and
destiny composer Marty O'Donnell's a
lawsuit claimed that Bungie violated
their contract with O'Donnell when they
fired him without cause and made him
give up his company stock and drop out
of bungees profit sharing plan O'Donnell
was awarded at least a hundred and forty
2,500 bucks Maya the first payment of
the profit participation program the
conversion was also previously awarded
almost 100k for unpaid work and legal
fees and is entitled to receive almost
200,000 spongy shares the suit was
initially filed in May of last year when
it was alleged to bungie president
harreld Ryan denied pay for unused
vacation time among other benefits
according to the court papers the
problems began when Oh Donald music was
replaced by Activision made music for a
destiny trailer shown at e3 2013
O'Donnell was none too pleased without
that decision and claimed he was trying
to preserve the spirit of spongy in the
face of what he called activision's
encroachment into our
decision crowell the latest on destiny
and everything else in gaming be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot